[Music]
I was going to say you look really nice
you always dress really well I've said
that to you before thank you I have I'm
vain you are not vain you're just a
smooth man mhm but you're also not like
a oblong size uh like
you true D you know sometimes it takes a
minute for them to understand our
Dynamic it is true yeah have do you feel
like America gets the idea that your
friends come on here and make fun of you
yet I I hope they're putting it together
cuz like when Chelsea was on you know
this is how we are the three of us will
go to brunch it'll be mostly me just
going you know what I mean but it's very
very funny yeah and and we're talking
about you which I love
yeah they need to understand that I like
that direct specific attention yes which
is why I enjoy being around you I
suppose a I'll shine my light on you
anytime well you do look sharp you look
smooth and sharp do you like being in
your 30s um I'm fine with it uh I feel
like I'm yeah do I like being in my 30s
I like the idea of being both of us uh
are are don't have kids uh but we have
uh uh TV shows yeah and so uh you know
it's pretty
[Laughter]
[Applause]
cool that is so insane and accurate it
is like having this weird kid yeah oh oh
I didn't even think about it that way I
like how I like that angle and I was
just more saying that like we have um uh
money but no
responsibility I took it as uh perhaps
maybe we don't have a a a deep source of
love we're more shallow on the surface
playing our new Xbox games but very
lonely reheating soup and looking at
frame the frame photo that came with a
frame picture of a family and you're
like ah what's that like yeah and then
you look down and you're getting
blown by the whole family in the frame
photo cuz they're just actresses and
actors they just see the
gig
um I love to reheat soup by the way
there's nothing wrong with reheating
soup soup is in itself just reheated
soup that's right that's right as you're
making soup you're reheating you're just
reheating it it's not like like a pasta
like for cold pasta you reheat that
congeals and turns into a new thing yeah
soup was is always soup soup is very
versatile like iced tea you leave it in
your car you come back it's just hot tea
right and he's like I want to go back to
Law and
Order I made the jump with you Nikki
thank
[Music]
you